quand la lumière du plateau s'est allumé
le 1er janvier 95
geneviève asselin présenté le premier
bulletin de rdi elle s'en souvient comme
si c'était hier
je crois que si on m'avait prise en
continu tout le temps on a revu ma tête
trembler les trois lettres que vous
voyez au bas de votre écran cigare dei
c'était alors une centaine d'artisans et
de journalistes prêts à inventer la télé
en direct une équipe de ligue 2 est
rempli d'ambition je me sentais comme
une espèce de pionnière une espèce
d'exploratrice puis je pense que c'est
un peu le sentiment qui nous anime est
tous dès ses premières années le réseau
de l'information fait sa marque quand
les nouvelles se déchaîne le déluge du
saguenay les attentats du 11 septembre
ne sait absolument rien de ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur
l'ouragan katrina si on n'est pas là au
moment où la nouvelle se se déroule on
fait pour notre travail
quand on arrive depuis ses débuts la
chaîne revêt une importance pour les
francophones du pays
marc andré masson en sait quelque chose
il a longtemps présenté l'ouest en
direct c était de donner une occasion
tout de suite à ce qui était partout au
pays d'avoir accès à aux ondes de
pouvoir être vue d'être entendu les
façons de faire ont évolué mais la
raison d'être de r10 reste la même
lorsqu'un événement majeur qui se
produit d'ailleurs on le voit très bien
dans les cotes d'écouté fluctue on va
voir une point pourquoi as tu gardé
comme un lieu de rassemblement
les gens se rassemblent pour voir les
images pour l'entente d'une grenade
assourdissante très probablement
l'assaut est en cours deuxième explosion
une des forces de rdc sa qualité de
service public
c'est sûr que quand on fait du direct le
risque d'erreur est très très élevé mais
je pense que rdi de manière générale a
maintenu sa réputation de qualité encore
témoin des grands événements
la chaîne d'info en continu doit
regarder vers la pluie fois loi en
quelque sorte se réinventer donc on voit
des formes journalistiques qui sont
adaptés pour le pour le web pour les
plateformes mobiles et qui se destine
souvent à des publics plus jeunes je
persiste jusqu'à croire puisque les
téléspectateurs sont là ils ont besoin
de verdi pour voir ce qui se pense et
comprendre ce qui se passe
tout était à faire à l'époque et tout se
fait encore 25 ans plus tard au rythme
de la nouvelle en continu alors ici
catherine gauthier radio canada montréal